Like we discussed earlier,
Power BI works well with a range of
data sources with new sources added on an ongoing basis.
Some of the Power BI data sources I really want to highlight for you are databases.
This includes SQL Server,
Azure Cloud Server, Oracle databases, and many others.
Power BI has quite an extensive list of databases available as data sources,
so if your organization uses one, it's probably available.
Social media, things like Facebook and LinkedIn,
online services commonly used for businesses,
and the options here are also quite extensive.
A few of them that jumped out to me were Salesforce,
Google Analytics, and QuickBooks.
There's also a number of big data software options including Hadoop, Spark, and Impala.
If you've been wondering what that yellow elephant has been doing in our prior slides,
that's the adorable symbol of Hadoop,
and of course, flat files and folders that hold
flat files are also an important part of the Power Query source universe.
These are your Excel files,
your CSVs, PDFs, and the folders that hold them.
So these are some of our possible data sources,
but how do we actually get to the data?
You're Get Data options is essentially the short answer to this,
and it would be impossible for us to go through how to connect to each and every
one of them given the sheer number of options available,
but as a general rule of thumb,
your data source will probably work if the data is structured in columns and rows,
and if you have the necessary access rights to use it.
There's a range of ways that you can take
data that doesn't have a preset way to connect to
Power BI itself and still make that data accessible for your data model if you need it.
Some of the options available to accomplish this are
web APIs or connections to the web in general where you can scrape data as well.
You can use open database connectivity or ODBC to make a connection to a vendor.
You can leverage either R or Python scripts to create a data connection,
or you can use Power Query SDK which
is a way that you can create a custom data connector for Power BI.
Most people will never really need to use
these more advanced options on their various Power BI adventures,
but I want you to know that these possibilities are available if you want or need them.
So if the two things that we mentioned before were true,
that's the columns and row structure and necessary access rights,
then thankfully the general steps to get and
transform the data are consistent regardless of the source.
You'll need to tell Power Query where the data is,
you'll need to provide credentials for that data source,
you'll need to choose the source tables to pull in,
and you're going to want to customize in Power Query to
tidy things up and transform the data so it works for the report you want to generate.
Once the source has been imported into Power Query,
it really is just another query regardless of the original source.
The way that you make changes to the data that came in from a CSV file, for example,
really will be the same as what you would do to a data set from SQL or Salesforce.